let's talk about this first story
because this is this is major breaking
news we have this from axios emergency
declaration issued in 17 states in dc
over fuel pipeline cyber attack so the
department of transportation's federal
motor carrier safety administration
administration issued a regional
emergency declaration for 17 states and
washington dc to keep fuel supply lines
open colonial pipeline carries 45 of
fuel supplies in the eastern u.s some
5500 miles of pipeline have has been
shut down in response to the attack so
if you're not familiar with this story
this is a ransomware attack basically
hit one of the systems at colonial i
don't know if it actually hit the
industrial control systems but their
computers
which basically means
their their their administrative
computers this co these hackers
have said unless you give us money we're
going to encrypt your machines you'll
never be able to use them they shut down
in responses it's typical of what
happens to companies when they do get
hit by this but this is a major attack
on our critical infrastructure now the
funny thing about this i think is that
uh the hackers have apologized have you
you guys you guys saw this they
apologized they said
my bad
yeah we won't take the money it was it
was they release it error of judgment on
our part
start shipping that oil again reopen the
east coast sorry
well so so uh the people who made the
ransomware i guess yeah said that we'll
have to vet our clients and
and implement moderation policies
definitely that's a good recommendation
there's some standards in these hacking
communities hacking communities have got
to get some standards how do they have
more standards than like the fed
well you know it's like when i was
living in harlem they used to say uptown
uh they're no cops because uh
you know you are the law the law you are
you have to be honest because there's no
cops
right so in the hoc in the hacker
community there's no cop so you have to
be honest there has to be standards so
so i guess basically these this this
hacker group what are they called
they're called dark side fbi names dark
side as the colonial pipeline cyber
attacker i guess they sold the
ransomware to someone yeah who then used
it
and ended up getting a pipeline you know
shut down
yeah if you're one of these hackers you
know you don't want the pipeline shut
down you you want to use your money for
stuff
so what's the point of getting the money
if like there's no oil what are you
going to do go buy a farm i guess well
it brings up you know a couple of points
the infrastructure in in the united
states is weak and getting weaker and
it's a huge problem and there's very
little funds to take care of it and also
you have uh the the ransomware and the
inability to deal with that is kind of a
secondary problem but
primarily the roads bridges tunnels
infrastructure pipelines oil pipelines
these things have gone neglected for
decades and now they're starting to fall
apart and the federal budget just
doesn't have any budget to to repair
these things the government the country
is already broke so and there and their
solution to him is always the same print
money
this is not real money
why
you cannot give it you want to spray
real money you can spend real money
well you told me i shouldn't rip up real
money don't rip up you know don't really
i was ready to shred another 20 000
bucks right here on the tim castle
you're like no no don't do it i'm like
listen i'm max kaiser i rip up money
that's what i do and tim's like no no
don't do it don't do it so i gotta use
the fake money i gotta use the fake
money but this is all they can do they
say oh the bridge broke let's print
money oh the pipeline's broke let's
print money oh uh we need more roads and
bridges let's print money oh there's not
enough minimum wage jobs let's print
more money that's all they know how to
do they don't know how to do anything
else that's the entire policy of every
freaking politician in america that's it
how much did they print last year
like uh 58 trillion dollars 50. no no no
no they increased the money supply by 25
so
um it goes it goes from yelling to
stacy's calm yeah yeah yeah yeah
they're just adding more zeros there's
no costumes it's like it's like remember
when zimbabwe wasn't zimbabwe where they
had like the billion dollar bills
trillions
yeah i like also that you know over the
past since 2008 they keep on pretending
like that they're all meeting together
all these academics and economists and
they're going to come up with a new plan
and it's all the same it's the same
exact money printing and they protect
they call it a new thing and they're
like now we're going to try this let's
let's so let's go back to the gas
pipeline real quick you mentioned uh go
to the wayback machine the wayback
machine infrastructure infrastructure's
crumbling
think about yeah think about computers
20 years ago or whatever when they built
the industrial control systems for these
pipelines yeah and that's that's that's
the level of technology many hackers
need to overcome and it's like
80s computer technology yeah they they
use uh what's that operating system from
the 80s and the 70s unix oh no cobalt
what they use
our entire banking infrastructure is on
cobalt
and there's only like three guys who
know how to program it wow and those
guys are you know uh paid a lot of money
hold on security through obscurity yes
yes yes they actually say that yeah i
know yeah it's a common phrase so what
happens is it's so archaic it may
actually be easy to hack but you're
going to get some like 18 year old
hacker and russia being like i have no
idea what this is
what is this language but there are only
like a handful of guys who still know
how to use it
speaking of uh like people being uh
like please work for us please please
like they're in retirement they're in
their 70s and they're like we just want
to be retired yeah yeah but our whole
banking infrastructure's about to
collapse come fix it it's crazy to me
that you had people they built up this
system and then basically shrugged and
walked away from it
and it's falling apart yeah yeah well
they're cheap
it's like um you know
but as max will also point out you know
the whole derivatives that the
complexity and the in the financial
system now is just so huge
that by the time like more advanced
stuff came around they they just didn't
know how to unwind any of it like it's
all
trapped in this old system yeah they
don't have to get it so so wait wait you
know
yeah i talk a bit about this watching
all the different stuff that's been
happening over the past few years
you know um police departments cops are
quitting like crazy riots are getting
more emboldened
uh
you know and i say things like it feels
like things are collapsing they're
falling apart there's a rot inside the
core
but you guys have been talking about
that for for way longer than i've been
around
so so you've been watching this spread i
mean especially from financial markets
particularly yeah because the markets
are rotten and the and the money that we
use is rotten the us dollar is rotten
yeah money is rotten goes back to the
1971 when nixon took us off out of the
gold standard essentially and the world
started on a very bold experiment every
country in the world had fiat money that
is this hey it's not backed by gold or
anything and so it became referential to
other fiat money so the dollar is valued
against the euro which is backed by
nothing back by the yen backed by the
chinese yuan it's all it's a circle jerk
that goes around and around and around i
think it's backed by
a bunch of people with guns telling you
it's worth something that's what paul
krugman says at the new york times he
says that the reason the dollar has
value is it's backed by men with guns
and um that's true it is that's why you
say fiat money is violence it promotes
violence it is violence and it is uh
promotes war the petro dollar certainly
is part of the us dollar matrix and that
is all about war and uh the cartel and
everything that goes on in the middle
east and it's all dollar related but if
they can just print out money as easily
as i can pull this trigger and fire off
some why can't they just fix our
infrastructure with it because they give
it to banks and the banks buy chateaus
and property on park avenue and jamie
dimon is a billionaire so occupy wall
street yeah yeah they have a problem and
that is that the us dollar has reserved
currency they can't they have to send it
overseas you can't you can't control the
world you can't have dollar hegemony you
can't have american hegemony without
sending those dollars overseas so they
don't spend it here because that would
cause inflation and they don't want
inflation so they send it to china they
send it to europe they send it to the
middle east and that is supposed to
sustain this hegemonic system if they
stop sending it overseas if they were to
start building factories and employing
people across michigan and iowa and
idaho and places like that then uh the
the dollar would no longer be the result
right right the trade deficit so dig
into it i mean go into the dig it dig it
dig into it some more i mean this is
really fascinating stuff this is the the
metal of it this is the triffen dilemma
that's called the tripping dilemma you
have to tell you what's going on well
the chiffon dilemma is something that
was warned about when we did bretton
woods back in 1944
and triffin had warned that uh the
problem with having a reserve currency
is that the that um your geo the
geopolitics versus your domestic
economics they they get into conflict
and that's the point we're at now we hit
it first in 1971
because
as the current as a reserve currency
country
we had to send all our dollars overseas
right
and that was backed by gold
so what you're doing is you're sending
your gold overseas and when france sent
their warship into the harbor of new
york to come collect their gold they got
their gold
england asked for their gold they didn't
get their gold we shut the gold window
but since 1971
what's the next step of the trip and
dilemma you send your manufacturing you
hollow out your manufacturing base and
that's what we've done we're at that end
point that's why you're seeing this
disintegration you know it's just the
entropy of the system it's the entropy
of the american empire of the dollar
system
things things disintegrate faster and
faster yeah yeah you guys know about the
fourth turning yeah yeah yeah we had uh
um um who was it was it ben norton uh
ben stewart ben stewart who's ben norton
i don't know cool name though yeah ben
norton is that left wing guy who works
with max oh that's right that's right
that's right well shout out ben wait no
we had ben stewart he was talking about
the uh the book and a lot of the stuff
that he was studying
and yeah i guess the the theory whether
it's true and a lot of people say it's
bunk it's just nonsense but uh no it's
good 2020 we've covered it
uh yeah well they wrote about it in the
1980s and they said it would be 2025
would be the year to look for they said
back then
so earlier uh i showed you guys um
we're going to we're going to release
the secret live on the air do it that
there is a secret room in this in this
building that no one knows about and in
it was uh food and beans and bullets and
yeah so good idea huh yeah yeah yeah
yeah it was uh it's good i want one i
want to live there can we can you rent
it
that could be like an airbnb well so we
had a tornado warning recently like
legit and like the the male lady came up
and she's like get inside now they just
called it in it's like there's a funnel
cloud it's coming right this way yeah
and so we go it's underground it's like
this underground thing
you know no windows it's literally just
edible gummy bears
that's all that's all that's in there
and yeah because the idea is if you're
going to die you want to just feel good
on the way
no no it's it's it's it's literally a
storage room um we have like
you know i don't know ian bought like 20
gallons of vinegar for some reason i'm
not done yet
but i don't want to get into it but fans
got it but
you guys are saying you know uh in in
the context of uh war and fourth turning
are you guys familiar with thucydides
trap yes we talk about that we have an
episode of our show called uh when uh
fourth turning meets acidity strap oh
wow yeah that's what's happening yeah
yeah it's not happened before has it no
yeah well
the oh maybe the two of them happening
together probably it's happened eighteen
times the thucydides right right sixteen
have ended violently for those that
aren't familiar it's basically um and
correctly if i'm wrong that when that
when a a rising economic power meets
is about to overtake the dominant power
war breaks out yes and that happened in
the past few years and you notice all
the propaganda against china sure china
is a different system than our own and
there are many problems with it
obviously but
we really started becoming very hostile
to them once they overtook us and 5g
artificial intelligence all the
high-tech stuff which remember joe biden
had mentioned back in 2000 when he was
you know encouraging uh congress to vote
to elevate them to the wto on favored
nation status he was like
uh china's gonna eat our lunch come on
man
it's not gonna happen no way
but you but it seems like you know biden
and many billionaires and big
corporations are totally deferential to
china if not absolutely supporting china
yeah they don't care they'll go where
the money is right exactly hollywood
edits they know
the favor chinese government and things
like that i think and the top gun in
china
tom cruise is actually chinese in the
cha in that in the release really no
well but i wouldn't be surprised if they
said he was well they did change a lot
of iconography because
you know they would change like the
story line but they got rid of the the
the tibet campaign or whatever from
taiwan taiwan that's what it was yeah
taiwan right yeah now i wouldn't be
surprised i did something like that in
in that one movie i remember what it was
they added the lines over the south
china sea yeah animated movie yeah so
it's like a little girl walks past a
world map and it's china and the lines
for the south china sea are like well
that's
trap so the china drives the global
economy and they're going to drive the
cultural agenda as well so the thing
that
the thing that changed the thing that
put us on the path towards a violent
conflict was 2014 the belt and road
initiative so what always happens is as
i was mentioning when you have the
world's reserve currency you have to
send your dollars overseas otherwise
there's because they can't print dollars
so you have to get it to circulate so uh
we were sending first we were sending
saudi arabia the europe they and they
kept recycling it back into treasuries
well that's what china did until 2014
then they started taking their dollars
and
uh lending it to africa lending it
across asia
to other nations and building
infrastructure and ports and stuff like
that
us us citizens yeah and uh america was
like wait
this
is cheating
it's not cheating really but it's uh
we're gonna say it's cheating when we
loan money to china are we borrowing it
from the federal reserve and then we owe
the interest to the federal reserve and
then loan it out or does the money get
loaned to the chinese and they owe the
interest to the federal reserve
uh well we
basically we owe them we have a trade
deficit with them so you have to run
massive trade deficits right when when
you have the reserve currency
so that's the lie that nobody will tell
the american people you know trump came
close to it when he was like make
america great again but the point is you
have to tell people like we either have
the reserve currency
or we have a domestic economy which do
you want and when you say we run a
deficit what is that exactly what is
that so uh china uh sends us say half a
bill say for ease say a trillion dollars
worth of goods and we only send them 200
billion worth of goods so they they send
us 800 billion more we we send them 800
billion more than we uh than we sell to
them they're getting more from us than
we're getting back is that what it is
yeah they they're selling us their goods
yeah you know and we're we sell them
less and less thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com tim
cast irl monday through friday at 8 pm
where you can leave comments and super
chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time
you